l'italie en deuil à l'annoncé lundi de
la mort de deux fonctionnaires italiens
en république démocratique du congo lors
d'une attaque armée nous activons toutes
les institutions compétentes pour
arriver le plus vite possible à
connaître la vérité sur cette attaque
abject qu'on subit deux serviteurs de
notre pays qui ont perdu la vie nous
faisons aussi tout notre possible pour
rapatrier leurs corps sybille parmi les
victimes
l'ambassadeur italien en rdc lucas on
t'a natio âgé de 43 ans il était en
poste depuis octobre 2019 il résidait
dans le pays depuis déjà deux ans ce
lundi il accompagnait un convoi de la
monusco la mission des nations unies
dans le pays depuis 20 ans l'attak a eu
lieu au nord de goma chef lieu de la
province du nord-kivu une région en
proie à des violences perpétrées par des
groupes armés depuis plus de 25 ans
blessé par balle à l'abdomen le cas en
tan as you est décédé dans un hôpital à
goma dans la foulée de la tacc les
forces armées congolaises ont lancé une
opération de recherche des auteurs
selon les autorités locales quatre
personnes auraient été kidnappées
une d'entre elles a depuis été retrouvés
ce lundi soir dans un communiqué le
ministère congolais de l'intérieur
accuse les rebelles hutu rwandais des
forces démocratiques de libération du
rwanda d'être responsable de l'attaqué
en convois du programme alimentaire
mondial a été victime d'une attaque
armée des éléments des forces
démocratiques de libération du rwanda à
kinshasa la capitale les habitants sont
sous le choc
c'est difficile pour nous n'arrivons pas
d'air à supporter ce communiqué message
là ça me fait vraiment très mal le
savoir qui est quelqu'un bien et puis
très jeune
mourir à cette circonstance là c'est
vraiment difficile et choquant pour nous
cette question de sécurité à lester
république démocratique du congo a fait
beaucoup de victimes et voilà
aujourd'hui tout le monde est concerné
un ambassadeur en poste à république
démocratique du congo vient de succomber
de son côté l'union européenne se dit
extrêmement préoccupé par l'annoncé de
la mort de l'ambassadeur d'italie
le pays a connu des précédents en 1993
c'est l'ambassadeur français philippe
bernard qui a trouvé la mort atteint
mortellement par une balle à la fenêtre
de son bureau à kinshasa